Transcriptor: Héloïse Gauvrit
Revisor: Almudena Torrecilla
Muy buenas tardes y
muchas gracias por estar aquí hoy,
en una tarde tan espléndida como esta,
aquí encerrados.
Yo soy Trinidad Guzmán
y soy, como decimos los de inglés
cuando nos ponemos estupendos,
“the odd one”, es decir, el bicho raro.
Porque yo soy la de Letras
de esta compañía con la que me honro.
Lo cual no quiere decir
que no tenga ciencia.
La mía, si quieren, es un poco una ciencia
que tira a lo esotérico sin serlo.
¿Por qué?
Porque yo me dedico a investigar
y a enseñar inglés medieval,
que es una lengua
con ocho declinaciones de nombres,
cinco declinaciones de adjetivos,
o diez conjugaciones, por ejemplo,
para los que piensen que
el inglés es una cosa fácil.
Y en inglés medieval está escrito
el libro del que les vengo a hablar hoy.
Miren, los libros de cocina
son un excelente mapa de carreteras
para los lingüistas de todo pelaje,
como es mi caso.
Y ¿esto por qué?
Pues como nos decía Camino hace un rato,
porque la cocina y la comida
dependen más que ninguna otra cosa
Y por ello probablemente
están absolutamente imbricados
con las tradiciones, con los mitos,
con los tabúes y con la religiosidad
de las culturas en las que surgen.
Lo curioso es que, además,
son una de las fuentes más fructíferas
y más sofisticadas de mestizaje.
Técnicas de cocina e ingredientes han
viajado y siguen haciéndolo hoy en día,
por caminos de peregrinación,
por rutas comerciales, e incluso
por campamentos de guerra.
Y con ellos las palabras que los designan.
Nuestro viaje comienza en 1066,
cuando Guillermo de Normandía cruzó
el canal de la Mancha o el canal Inglés,
depende del lado en que se mire,
y acabó coronándose rey de Inglaterra,
tras derrotar al último rey sajón
en la batalla de Hastings.
Desde entonces y durante
unos cuantos siglos,
los destinos de Francia y de Inglaterra
permanecerían unidos,
sobre todo a raíz del matrimonio
de Enrique II Plantagenet de Inglaterra
y Leonor de Aquitania.
Fueron muchas las generaciones
de reyes y de nobles ingleses
que se casaban con nobles,
con príncipes franceses,
que nacían o se educaban en Francia
y que pasaban mucho tiempo allí,
en defensa de sus posesiones
y sus intereses franceses.
Entre ellos, el rey
Ricardo II de Inglaterra,
en cuya corte surgió el libro
que me interesa esta tarde,
y que yo he traducido como
“Espejo del arte de cocina”.
Este rey nació en Burdeos en 1367, porque
su padre, que era el príncipe de Gales,
gobernaba un poco a modo de entrenamiento,
antes de heredar la corona inglesa,
las posesiones inglesas
del sur de Francia.
El libro es uno de los muchos que
han llegado de la época medieval
hasta nuestros días.
No solamente de Inglaterra,
sino de muchas otras partes.
Por cierto, que no espere un cocinillas
que se acerque a estos libros,
ninguna indicación, ni de cantidades
de ingredientes ni de tiempos de cocción.
Y ello, porque no estaban pensados para
enseñar a cocinar desde el principio,
sin saber nada.
No. A cocinar se aprendía como
en todos los oficios medievales,
en este caso, de pinche en la cocina.
Los libros de cocina
como este, los recetarios,
estaban pensados para que
no se te olvidaran las ideas,
un poco para presumir de
“hay que ver qué bueno soy”,
y también para dar ideas a los demás,
como se nos dice en este caso
en el prólogo de este libro.
En este prólogo, también se nos dice
que las recetas han sido compiladas,
y cito así un poco de memoria,
con el acuerdo y el consejo de
los doctores en Filosofía y en Medicina
de la corte del rey Ricardo.
Ese consejo y ese acuerdo
estaba basado en esto:
en la teoría hipocrática
de los cuatro humores,
que era de general uso y conocimiento
durante toda la Edad Media.
Del equilibrio de esos cuatro humores
dependía la salud mental
y la salud física del individuo.
La alimentación era una parte
muy importante,
no solamente los alimentos
que se ingerían,
sino también el modo de prepararlos.
Por otra parte, el orden al que
estamos acostumbrados, hoy en día,
también es una novedad.
Todo lo novedoso que se puede decir
cuando estamos hablando
del período medieval.
Una especie de mezcla entre
estos principios hipocráticos
y los hábitos y las costumbres
de servir de las mesas árabes,
que estaban entrando a través de
la península ibérica en toda Europa,
especialmente y por lógica en el sur
y luego más para arriba.
Las recetas son de todo tipo,
las que aparecen aquí,
en el “Espejo del arte de cocina”.
Están las de diario y
las que son más de fiesta.
Entre las de diario está uno de los platos
más veganos que ha habido en el mundo,
que es esta sopa de pan y puerros,
que tienen aquí.
En cuanto a los platos de carne,
pues bueno, los más frecuentes,
los más de días de diario,
eran los hechos a base de vaca,
de carnero, de gallina,
de conejo, que ¡ojo!, también era
toda una novedad en el momento,
porque no los había en Inglaterra
antes de la conquista, solo había liebres.
Los llevaron los normandos.
En cuanto a los pescados, pues los que se
podían encontrar por allí habitualmente:
anguilas, tencas, bacalaos,
salmón y marsopas.
Que no es que no supieran que
las marsopas son mamíferos, no.
Lo que sabían era mucha gramática parda.
Y como las marsopas se pescaban
porque eran animales marinos,
eran la mejor de las excusas,
para saltarse el precepto de
abstención de carne en la Cuaresma.
Todo ello se aderezaba
con hierbas aromáticas,
la mayoría, las que
se encontraban en el país,
y con especias.
Y aquí es donde viene otro de estos
famosos clichés de la Edad Media,
según el cual las especias se utilizaban
sobre todo para disimular
materias primas que, o no
eran de muy buena calidad,
o estaban en un más que dudoso
estado de conservación.
Pues parece ser que no.
Parece ser que el uso de las especias
dependía bastante del gusto,
y sobre todo del poder adquisitivo
del que las utilizaba.
Porque cuanto más sofisticado,
cuanto más lujoso era un plato, como
los que servían en banquetes de este tipo,
más especias llevaban
y más se acumulaban.
Hay que tener en cuenta que muchas
de las especias eran muy caras,
porque se importaban de muy lejos.
Lo cual me lleva de nuevo
a la historia del mestizaje.
En este caso, a través del culinario,
el mestizaje cultural y
el mestizaje lingüístico,
que es en el que yo trabajo habitualmente.
Miren, aún hoy en día, en
el vocabulario del inglés moderno,
un 30 % de palabras son
de procedencia francesa.
La mayoría de ellas entraron
entre los siglos XIII y XV.
Este “Espejo del arte de cocina”
es un texto del siglo XIV.
Muchas de las palabras de arte culinario,
por no decir una inmensa mayoría,
son de origen francés.
Entre ellas están las de
determinados ingredientes.
Aquí lo he puesto con
la ortografía del inglés medieval,
pero seguro que la reconocen bien.
Espinacas, almendras o azafrán.
Preparaciones como las tartas,
la gelatina, los pochados o las charlotas.
Nombres propios de algunos platos,
como el sambocade o los chasteletes,
así, por decirlo fino.
Y por otro lado,
instrumental:
útiles de cocina, como esa especie
de cazo que se llamaba “possynet”,
o un peculiar colador.
Todas ellas son importaciones culturales.
Es decir, o bien cosas que no existían
en la Inglaterra del momento,
o que sí existían,
pero eran de otra manera.
Sin embargo,
procedimientos o materiales
absolutamente esenciales y cotidianos,
eran y siguen siendo hasta hoy,
palabras de la lengua inglesa.
Como moler, huevos, leche,
gallinas, agua, fuego o puerros.
Quiero detenerme
en este par de ingredientes
y recetas que me parecen muy importantes.
El aceite de oliva, “oil”,
y los “fryttes”,
como estos de manzana por ejemplo,
que también es una receta del libro.
Resulta que en el “Espejo
del arte de cocina” encontramos,
y eso sí que fue una sorpresa para mí,
muchas, muchas recetas,
en las que el paso fundamental
era freír en aceite de oliva
en un libro inglés de cocina
de la Edad Media.
Claro, no se puede olvidar
la influencia gala del rey,
que había nacido y se había criado
en el sur de Francia.
Pero hay otras dos cocinas
que son de absoluta importancia
en este libro y en los libros de,
digamos, lujo de cocina medieval.
Una, es la influencia
de la cocina hispanoárabe
y la otra, la influencia
de la cocina italiana.
Vamos con la hispanoárabe,
y con esta receta:
la receta del manjar blanco.
Es una de las hojas del libro
de cocina, por cierto.
El manjar blanco me va a permitir además,
contarles una pequeña historia de espías.
Para que se hagan una idea de lo que es,
es como la masa de croquetas
de gallina, pero a lo bruto,
por lo contundente de los ingredientes
que lleva y de la preparación.
Y ahora viene la historia.
Ricardo II,
el rey que auspició este libro,
era hijo del famoso príncipe negro,
que anduvo allá por Castilla,
enredando en las guerras civiles
entre Pedro I el Cruel y los Trastámara.
Pues bien, a mediados del siglo XX,
mis colegas de otra universidad,
dentro del área de Filología Inglesa,
descubrieron un salvoconducto
a nombre de un alto funcionario
de la corte inglesa,
que seguramente estaba en España en
algún tipo de misión diplomática secreta,
de la que nos enteramos entonces.
Hasta ahora no habíamos sabido de ella.
Ese funcionario se llamaba
Geoffrey Chaucer,
y es uno de los grandes, grandísimos
nombres de la literatura inglesa,
el autor de los cuentos de Canterbury,
que es a su vez, uno de los grandes
monumentos del medievo europeo.
En esos cuentos aparece un cocinero.
Un cocinero, una de cuyas especialidades
era precisamente el manjar blanco.
No es improbable que Geoffrey Chaucer
dejara de probar el manjar blanco
mientras estuvo en España.
Por cierto, que los franceses
han reclamado en sus revistas
el origen del manjar blanco como suyo,
de la zona del Languedoc.
Bueno, yo investigo
en lingüística, no en historia.
Pero lo que sí es cierto, es que antes que
los libros de cocina medievales franceses
o el “Espejo del arte de cocina”,
hay una fórmula de manjar blanco
en el libro de Sent Soví,
que es un recetario catalán,
un siglo al menos anterior a todos ellos.
Y por otra parte, no se puede olvidar
que el arroz y las almendras,
que son componentes de
esta masa de croquetas potente,
son de origen levantino.
La versión dulce, por cierto,
del manjar blanco,
sigue siendo hoy un postre popular,
hasta el Renacimiento
hubo “manjarblanqueros”
vendiéndolo por toda España,
y es sobretodo muy, muy fácil de encontrar
en muchos países de Hispanoamérica.
En cuanto a la conexión italiana,
pues tenemos la lasaña.
La lasaña que entonces consistía en placas
más o menos confeccionadas
como las de hoy,
hervidas en caldo y montadas intercalando
un queso tipo crema fuerte,
y, por supuesto, con el montón
de especias de rigor.
¿Echan algo de menos,
aparte de la carne picada?
Miren, si el viaje del yanqui
a la corte del rey Arturo,
que se hizo en la novela de Mark Twain,
lo hubiera hecho mi abuela,
cocinera de oficio,
a la despensa del rey Ricardo II,
a la pobre se le hubiera caído
el alma a los pies.
Porque lo único que hubiera podido cocinar
de todo aquello que le hizo legendaria
entre sus jefes y su familia,
hubieran sido las croquetas,
con huevo frito dentro también,
es verdad, pero solo las croquetas.
Ni su salsa de tomate,
ni sus patatas guisadas,
ni su chocolate a la taza.
Añadan cualquiera de nuestros platos
más habituales hoy en día:
tortilla de patata, gazpacho, pisto,
guisantes con jamón o, si nos ponemos así,
unas humildes palomitas de maíz.
La verdad es que si tuviéramos
que confeccionar un menú
a partir del “Espejo del arte de cocina”
o cualquier otro menú
auténticamente medieval,
nos saldría, para nosotros hoy en día,
un menú mucho más marciano
del que nos habló Manolo hace un rato.
Porque claro,
cuando maese cocinero cogió
el cálamo en la cima de su profesión
para redactar ese libro de cocina,
faltaba aún más de un siglo para 1492.
Muchas gracias.